secondo
nuovissima prigione robles
evviva le nostre preferite anche le
vostre preferite
potete vedere siamo in prigioni
nuovamente ritenete da dietro di te
sicuramente evitare sta mangiando
qualcosa di razza qualche fatto un altro
porterà lo so dove sono finito
guardate la guardia che ci ha
imprigionato e questo è un po strana
cioè perché mancanza sulla maglietta
cos'è comunque la scopriremo a steve
miracolosa lo stato bene mi piace
presidi borgo cosa da mangiare qualcosa
da bere e iniziamo subito la nostra che
provai allora tenetevi una difficoltà a
farsi più difficile facile facile io
dico fare facile carità qui ecco la
solita si sta guardando
e qui ho preso in prima persona perché
ce l'ha ferito che questo gioco in prima
persona e che facevo dire cioè che noi
vediamo
direttamente tramite gli occhi del
personale adatto a noi stessi in realtà
esso mette in prima persona
allora che facciamo rumore e di risalire
questa è una freccia presto saremo sopra
un'altra presenza e guardiamo adesso
corpo era
bravissimo giocare in prima persona per
noi è molto più coinvolgente e londra
proprio di essere lì dice lei
punching ok di tirare pugni qua
ma penso basti tu quello che si
no
no non mi spinge è un po più difficile
si
procede non ci credo come ho fatto cose
si straccerà vitale il miglior in
commenti di almeno 1 superato eccovi
qualcosa c'è
batte tutti i vestiti uguali e beh sì
siamo dei prigionieri si può premere un
pulsante che cosa succede non lo so
riproviamo 20 20 08 avesse diventato
rosso a ecco perché vedi guarda bisogna
stare qua sopra però
ora basta camera
disegnata da farti cadere allora uno
alla volta bisogna andare qui
da chi sei caduta è difficilissimo e
oplà evviva ce l'ho fatta
io adesso scappo riusciremo a scappare
l'upload di prum se ne sono guardati
eccolo è preciso
si chiama mario e steve berry quindi
dobbiamo scappare dalla ati ha preso
mamma mia che brutta
io sono scappato ma perché riguarda solo
mesi sono un sacco di altre personalità
perché ha detto fammi scegliere quella
più schiappa
dove evitare annunci credo
caspita è molto agile mister barry
nonostante la sua non si direbbe visto
quella pancetta
fatica
aspettando primo a darmi
sempre tirato vitale mi ha superato alla
grado e ascom a passare non capisco il
perchè devo assolutamente superare
vitale guarda che si sogna premere il
bottone la sotto se prima era davvero
impegnata a crica scoraggiato visto che
sia stato mister vero aiuto quindi sarà
solo uno dei branchi se non si prevedono
d'armi se non si preme il bottone non si
può entrare
davvero che scoprirete perché uno
scorreggione ok vado a premere il
bottone prima che vivere deve sapere
bravo
aiuto aiuto aiuto mi chiamo amore
che abbia
arredi poco fa troppo ridere quando
scoreggia
ok per me ma non riesce a salire non è
abbastanza agile ma ancora non si è
riusciti ad entrare qui dai corridoi
sono in bagno sentivo di non credere
questa volta passiamo qua allora ci sono
un po di potere
sto arrivando
davvero
ma chi sa scorreggione
da rifugio è bagnato
allora sono riuscito con qualche scoria
chimica hardy e verde qua intasato la
testa ora voglio vedere in ogni bagno
cosa non c'è
alcuna scavato qua io sono qui
eccoti ti vedo così scesa la sera lo
cadere nella lava per silvia binetti eh
sì perché abbiamo scavato e quindi
accaduto giovani quindi quale palline
gelava o no temo nei sotterranei della
prigione
io sono qui sul ponte su col ponte che
vederli però finora di st bruno vv
senz'acqua troppo bella
[Musica]
[Risate]
a proposito volevo ringraziarvi
tantissimo perché in tantissimi avete
già preso storie paura dei ministeri il
mio libro vi sta piacendo tantissimo vi
iscrivete ogni giorni caldissimi su
instagram sia poi così i genitori rom
per carini grazie grazie grazie c'è chi
la vita in un giorno è infatti questo
libro una volta che iniziato a leggerlo
non riuscito di leggerlo vi lascerà col
fiato sospeso
grazie mille davvero anche per tutte le
recensioni che ci state lasciando su
amazon leggiamo ogni giorno se non lo
avete ancora preso non potete non averlo
stories devil e cliccate nel link in
descrizione per prenderlo subito e ora
superiamo vitale e va quindi quali il
ponte stiro ciao ciao
e grazie una cosa pero
ci hai fatto brava propone vittorie
paura è un caso sono entrata acqua con
il teschio spetta a non cadere perché ci
sono degli spuntoni di ferro 8
bellissimo e adesso dove andiamo qui è
diventata una prigione del cast della
sotterranea è passata dai fatti spiace
carino e testato una palla piena di
fuoco
per un pelo ok c'è mancato poco attento
io mi nascondo quasi nascondiamoci ecco
che ricava
dalla poca vita né nomi né
spiaccicate riusciti a portare tutte
divaricati annuncia guardia adesso è
mister barry come ho fatto ad arrivare
qui dobbiamo scappare adesso il rosso
non devi farti vedere
il proprio cane di qua mia rete ma passa
attraverso che penso a fare bene con
armatura mi ha preso che a me e che
succede solo in testa di un giocatore
vista trascorsa
beh grati per il passaggio ma ma vadano
a porta dal sesso davvero lei io invece
se non riuscito a scappare parte qua ci
sono queste scale così un corrotto che
cosa questo un pulsante si riprende
quello deve provare quando no non hai
fatto in tempo sei riuscito a passare
sono andato avanti simo come hai fatto
allora dopo che premi in quel pulsante
devi entrare in quella in quella porta
allinea quindi vai subito ha preparato
il pulsante ai corridori con libero
punto ce l'hai premuto le più mi scappa
ok sì comm'a le ha premuto importanza
godere dei 366 ma ottimi domandati corri
corri coniglio grigio ma adesso deve
saltare sopra con le scale ma detto che
finiscono per
basta continua ad autorizzare mamma vi
costerà non è salito qua sopra
dovreste io sono qua sopra alla fine
dell'adolescenza grande così ti vedo
andiamo
noi siamo qua e
non mi fido premere questo punto antero
su sappiamo se fosse un ascensore
richiamo dove finiremo speriamo che ci
sia un drago
siamo quasi al piano superiore via 18
nella caffetteria oppure nella stanza di
sicurezza stanza di sicurezza direi
proprio che tu non vedere nella
caffetteria a mangiare
ho
preso una bibita
d'italia
io invece vi sono sfracellato
mi sono ri sfregio e manco stare attento
quali sono morti
a
brugola d'oro non capisco perché mi
sfracello sempre devi stare attento a
prendere bene la mira
ok prova a prendere un'altra latina non
emergevano ancora la velocità non mi fa
doveva prendere un'altra comunque io
sono riuscito a passare mia età o parata
euro sulle grate poi mi sono stragelato
che ci posso credere non pari a
combinare altre distrazioni ho
ricominciato
ho sentito il rumore un tonfo possiamo
farcela star estremi lasciate mi piace
per portarci fortuna e superare questo
stage difficilissimo
c'è mancato poco perché canzone l'ho
fatto non ci credo non ci credo che
l'hai fatta bene vitale ce l'ha fatta
dove porterà prima a che prendiamo bene
la milanese è ancora all'inizio ma
faccio tantissima ma che in genere fa
cado sempre
ok ce l'ho fatta
perché se una schiappa
dai no tav manca poco un mondo manca
ancora un po
ecco io sono lì
integrate
ti stavo per dire che quella era una
parte difficile dei ragazzi sei una
volta bufera 150 volte dai sbrigati
occupanti vita nella giu
questo è il momento fatidico vediamo
[Applauso]
los continuo ok ragazzi mi sono
sfracellata tu ti senta volte che
prenderò che cosa volevo diretto vediamo
abbiamo scelta ecco posso volare vi
piace oppure queste sorta di arpione con
cui vi posso appendere alle superficie
con non è meglio il jetpack che segua
questo praticamente distrugge gli altri
personaggi questo caso no non mi serve e
questo dà la scossa agli altri
personaggi telecinesi per muovere cosa
avesse guardato
non lo so che cosa fa un sacco di cose
ti fa fare ma tra questo
scelgo dire
ok usate spandere numero
come tutte la tua ex
visto che devi andare vai avanti con le
frecce
figlio
bellissimo
ciao ciao a tutti secondo te dove devo
andare non lo so qua sotto porta si sono
scoprire tutto qui marin è
troppo bello volare eccoti di vento sta
scendendo al petto posso superare questo
o come va veloce eccoli qua ti fai
per lei anche ad effetto dove siamo
ma che senso ha spaventato non sapevo
che era un altro giocatore
acqua c'è un attore showroom allora non
applicare questo pulsante prima nota che
ti fa ricominciare marche bello c'è di
che carpa nella scala e io prendo un
ascaro auto a cosa serve ma ce la
dobbiamo portare da qualche parte dai
perché con la scala
dove i prigionieri parlano ma guardo
ciao miliari e se c'è scritto qui tra
l'altro trova una scala entrate ha
probabilmente qua sopra dobbiamo salire
li
guarda e adesso come facciamo a salire
lo so vediamo proviamo allora bisogna
saltare e poi
anche la stesa però bisogna praticarla
non vediamo
ma
sicuramente l'eni fuori dal gioco si
sono riuscito a salire sulla scala
con il mio gesto
non siamo rimasti fuori dalla prigione
quindi questo è il condotto di area
e attendono che lo sostiene soprattutto
tra mi sono accorta arrivato candidato
porto è vero o non vero cascina è adesso
dove devo andare da qui
e capitola ok
cosa c'era di là noi stiamo bene
giochiamo vigili hanno uscita è super
difesa è davvero l'equilibrio rai
ecco come non detto prendi bene le
misure
che ho per dire guarda che io sono bravo
ma mi sa di no di zac mi sbaglio piano
piano
calma
sarei fatta non mi sono sfaccettato di
nuovo la
crescita e non potevo fatto da evitare
poi parte la facciamo tutti il tifo per
terzo dovete mangiare non sono da record
apre così difficile dai puoi farcela
siamo qua
allora chiudi la valvola questa è una
valvola e quali malgrado sia quella
rossa aspetta ce n'è anche un'altra
libero
che è successo come fatto e mi fa andare
a quello al perché non alcuna come no no
sicuramente sarà quest'altra ce n'è
un'altra epoca ha chiuso la valvola
altra labbra si sono domandati se i
pezzi a
tavola volando al vero perché deve
chiuderla anche tu no no no sono
riuscito a sono riuscito bra crema sono
create spettatori comandare ok ti credo
che dobbiamo andare qua ma perché non
riesco a saltare la sopra io paura di
cadere c'è una strada qua dai ok ecco
che credo che ce l'abbiamo quasi fatta
note caduto si d'acqua non so dove
bisogna andare quindi jeff
che è bello volare dai salta di qua
dobbiamo saltare lo capisco dal lato
credo credo dal lato go che ho mai obolo
che bello volare
eccomi
e ora via
toti caduto proprio qui guarda c'è uno
strumento l'abi attento e ma
la velocità la sua velocità
[Musica]
o no devi stare super attento saltare in
continuazione e mi sono accorto sono
tantissimi ho visto sfracellato da
evitare puoi farcela certo io volo nel
frattempo
dimostracelo facciamo tutti il tifo per
te ma tu sei andato con cefac sì perché
marino protetto signori di balsa
permettono troppo difficili questi cosa
super velocità non so perché non ci
capisci
eccoci qua voi lo sapete che anche con
il joystick si sono sprecati 500.000
volte non so perché ma ho prende il
posto di vita era ora trovo io che mio
fratello che di tante volte abbiamo
verso l'alto
o si vuole ma quindi vogliamo anche
senza ce l'ha fatta ma
non capisco dentro porta dentro piazzato
ma non ci riesco a fare puoi farcela
ecco forse ci sono o no siamo tornati in
prigione ma questa volta la guardia e il
cuoco che bello si mangiò finalmente
sopra le righe chef smith aiuto perché
dobbiamo fare qui adesso sto perché dice
che alla barra della vita abbia tirato
qualche chiamata sembrava bazooka
aspetta aspetta
fu di zuca ci aspetteranno nel 58 chiaro
lo dobbiamo lo dobbiamo colpire così fa
ma dobbiamo colpire si ha un bellissimo
questo accettato costi accennando alla
pineta
non lo so mi ha spiegato
abbiamo capito quello che dobbiamo fare
ecco il food zucca andiamo a prendere il
food zucca a cielo già colpissero e
tocca a scappare pure
non so cosa vi sto tirando ma divertente
però esitato a fare un po di cino via
scalabrini
artificiali di cibo vedi tutelando
panini se mi piacerebbe tantissimo
questo cosa droga mi sto tirando un
ananas
il pomodoro gli ho tirato una patata se
la sconfitta non malese inca prossimo il
tavolo sono riuscito a sconfiggerlo la
vita non cambia la vita aspetta spara
vai
a fare un po tra uno e l'altro no
il denaro aspetta a fermo lì un momento
dove sei no
ti sparo
pubblico parino un po d'oro cresta il
sogno di evitare che io di mare
dove dobbiamo andare
vediamo non lo so forse qua vediamo sì
forse lì la si aspetta adesso abbiamo
sconfitto lo chef che no mia tu sei food
zucaro
tv scivolando qua sotto e voi
e siamo
solo sfracellato mezz'aria ok saliamo
qua ci sei si sono più tono dei ancora
tempera cercando di mangiare il cibo da
rim di zucca io non ho esposto un panino
in tasca però è uscita c'è l'uscita no
non ci credo ce l'abbiamo fatta sei una
strumento la fretta e frecce
attento no vabbè difficilissimo
stiamo volando meglio wow
tu sei riuscita non so come sono ancora
viva non lo so
bisogna evitare no no no no no adesso
solo sull'angolo aiuto ok se l'ho
trovata non capisco che io non capisco
dove sono
wow come abbiamo fatto a passare questi
wales e ora dove dobbiamo andare se c'è
scritto funziona freccia proviamo a
risalire qua dobbiamo trovare qualcosa
di metallo e accogliere questi una grata
di metallo per passare dall'altra parte
fitto
non ci sono infatti le punte la sotto
dove
roberto lo riprendo wow e passo quatu
figo
benissimo ok devi prenderlo poi
ok e ora
qua ha dormito ma è davvero bellissima o
no cosa è successo se berio gary o come
si chiama con un robot con un mega
mitragliatore adesso dice di sparare
alle braccia ma con che cosa
al food un bazooka per poter giocare
o no vabbè a testa ci sono anche le
altre guardie non c'è mai vista di
quello no o no mi sta proprio posta
irene ed abbiamo fatto respiro ma anche
con quel nome
beckett stana no no è appreso no
350 quasi mia sfracella e concentriamoci
quindi
diamoci subito buzduca becca di questa
eppure queste marino no vabbè però non è
giusto noi al mega robot
mara cibo o no no aspettarci sei tu
dietro
non riesco a prenderlo non ho finito le
munizioni
asterisco ok quello l'ho fatto fuori
davis in cartelle braccia alle braccia
non avevo capito
devo scappare permesso
ehi tu sei fermo laggiù è sì sto
cercando di colpire solo un braccio alla
volta
o aiuto di un prezzo un braccio dov'è
ok tu e ad intascare scappare
se riusciremo a mettere ko quel braccio
non so cosa sta succedendo non ci credo
non
puoi farcela noi vicino a me riscoprendo
ruota un prato di moro dobbiamo salire
sopra questo non lo so che cos'è un
cappuccino
tutto parte tu devi prendermi un altro
mondo dai dopo
guardate la mia vita troppo figo anch'io
ero stata a qualcos'altro da sconfiggere
spero che abbiamo vinto
siamo nel deserto visto ancora guidando
faticato che cos'è spetta adesso
dai datemi il badge e siracusa c'è
qualcosa di nascosto qui dietro questa
roccia parliamo con il jeff beck però
vediamo salire
6 belgio patto tra itali sali e ti
aspetta il vecchio
[Musica]
ce l'abbiamo fatta
ma che cosa c'è un portale
o no non funziona ha teletrasportato in
questa barriera del tetto veste volete
parliamo anche questa schifosa più belli
mi piace è una delle quattro case linee
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao